[Música]
era un día normal de cuarto grado y las
mezclas me pidieron hacer un trabajo
este trabajo consistía en que yo debía
comparar a dos países en este caso y
ellos me asignaron a méxico y alemania
durante la investigación uno de los
datos que más llamó mi atención por la
cantidad de premios nobel que cada uno
de los países había generado en este
caso alemán tenían 106 y méxico
únicamente 3 los cuales aún siguen
vigentes este y muchos otros datos que
descubrí durante este trabajo me dejaron
ver la enorme diferencia entre la vida y
oportunidades de alemanes y mexicanos
méxico es un país maravilloso con una
riqueza cultural natural y lingüística
inviables
pero lamentablemente azotado por la
pobreza y la corrupción cuando era más
pequeño me formulan a preguntar una
pregunta que quizás haya pasado por la
mente de los aquí presentes y es que
hubiera sido nacer en un país del
llamado primer mundo mi vida seguiría
siendo igual
de ahí viene otra porque las cosas son
así porque hay países muy grandes muy
chiquitos que están muy en el norte o en
el sur esto se lo pregunten papá el cual
me responde con una historia de la
cápsula un capítulo de historia mundial
desde entonces tuvimos prácticas que
eran una especie de clase de historia
improvisada informal en donde quieras un
estudiante y el maestro una de las
historias que más recuerdo que me contó
fue en la que me dice que en el méxico
prehispánico y existen las escuelas en
las cuales se les enseñaba a los jóvenes
desde los 15 años a poder sembrar a arar
matemáticas ciencias historia geografía
entre muchas otras materias más sin
embargo las que más les importaban y en
las cuales se les inculcaban los valores
morales a los niños lo cual creo yo soy
yo perdiendo poco a poco desde la
llegada de los españoles los cuales algo
en el sistema que ya existían que
existía lo derrocaron e impusieron el
suyo en el cual el indígena rápidamente
aprendió a agachar la cabeza ente del
español el sentimiento de inferioridad
se arriesgó en nuestra cultura ahí fue
cuando creo yo está fue enterrada para
dar paso a las grandes catedrales
construcciones europeas y su misión
española de los gobiernos extranjeros
que nos ponen los españoles pasamos a
los malos gobiernos a los gobiernos
corruptos que ahora les convenía mucho
más tener un polo ignorante ya que la
falta de conocimiento nos esclaviza en
algún momento en nuestra historia la
educación se confunde con su misión
educar con tomar y aprender con acceder
a ser domados y yo creo que esto no sólo
pasó en la alta política y dentro de las
aulas sino también en los hogares donde
los padres rápidamente aprendieron a
domar a sus hijos esto se lo
transmitieron a eso
hijos y así sucesivamente hasta que hoy
en día sigue habiendo padres que creen
que educar a sus hijos significa
literalmente tomarlos y tomarlos como si
los jóvenes y niños fuéramos seres sin
voluntad en entendimiento y lo acepto
nosotros venimos con un chip que nos
hace ser rebeldes que nos hace querer
experimentar e ir más allá de nuestro
hogar más sin embargo la buena madre
naturaleza nosotros también de un
cerebro que aprende mucho mejor en un
ambiente cálido y enriquecido y no en
uno en el que sólo seamos nombrados
educar o domar si se fijan utilice mucho
estas dos palabras en la diapositiva
anterior así que vamos a ver qué
significa primero educar se refiere a
desarrollar las facultades intelectuales
morales efectivas de una persona
dependiendo con las normas de
convivencia y la cultura a la que ésta
pertenece en cambio a domar tenemos una
que se aplica desde los humanos y otra
aplica hacia los animales la de los
humanos es hacer tratar una persona que
no lo es y moderar su aspereza de
carácter sus ganas de experimentar y sus
ganas de siempre es el rebelde sin causa
en cambio la de los animales también se
refiere a domesticar o someter un animal
para comer es que al ser humano esto
muchas veces se logra a base de amenazas
y castigos educar y domar no son
sinónimos educar implica desarrollar lo
mejor de una persona en cambio tomar
simplemente es controlarla en beneficio
del tomador y de la sociedad no del
individuo en el primero de estos dos
casos educar tiene un propósito
altruista en el segundo de marc tiene un
propósito está
las costumbres que se hacen ley
si lo que siempre se espera de nosotros
es una audiencia ciega los niños muchas
veces aprendemos a suprimir nuestras
iniciativas nuestras ideas y nuestra
actividad con tal de tener a nuestros
padres contentos y tranquilos
esto nos lleva a como ya dije en un
principio a suprimir nuestra iniciativa
para seguir las costumbres que nos
tuvieron atados a esa niñez durante toda
nuestra vida y porque digo esto porque
si sin iniciativa no habrá personajes
como luis miramontes guillermo gonzález
camarena o maría molina aclamados
hombres de ciencia mexicanos
muchas veces yo creo que los jóvenes y
los niños que pudieran ser la siguiente
generación de grandes físicos y
científicos son cortados de su
inspiración en sus ideas para vivir en
un mundo burbuja en donde todo es
meticulosamente controlado por los
padres ellos controlan que nada te
lastima a ti que nada de la autoestima
de ellos o al gato
esto muchas veces hace que los niños no
podamos tener ese espacio mágico que
tenemos nosotros los niños para
experimentar para ver si tomar una
decisión está bien o mal y sentirlo en
carne propia típicas abuelitas mamás
tíos padres o incluso los maestros nos
dicen frases como estas a veces todos
los días las típicas eres un bueno para
nada gracias a sí porque lo digo yo no
te metas que es plática de adultos y la
que creo yo que es más explícita en
cuanto a
la afectación que tiene así en este
desarrollo es típica de un tal
que estaba haciendo algo en su cuarto
entonces el papá de le dice
machito ven aquí entonces él responde
que y el papa le vuelvo a decir nos dice
que se dice mande obviamente en un tono
mucho más fuerte
pero si analizamos esta situación el
padre le está enseñando a a que
él siempre esté a costas de que alguien
les diga que hacer es decir que nunca
salga de ese pequeño margen de que
alguien mayor le diga a sus órdenes
muchas veces los padres creen que el
camino para tener a niños bien educados
es enseñarles a obedecer en parte esto
es cierto eso es importante pero todos
tienen sus límites a veces los padres
toman todas las decisiones difíciles por
nosotros y nunca podemos aprender a
tomar las nuestras esto me está pasando
a mí ustedes saben yo voy a en sexto de
primaria y entonces me van a pasar en
secundaria en primaria los maestros se
dicen cuando tienes que copiar cuando
tienes que poner atención si te lo van a
calificar si va a valer para tu
calificación en fin un montón de
acciones que ellos hacen para que te des
cuenta de qué hacer en cambio secundaria
las maestras y mis papás me cuentan que
esto ya no es así
es decir que si nunca hubiera habido esa
maravillosa maestra de inglés que desde
principios de años nos empezó a tocar
así probablemente el siguiente año al
entrar el primer día al salón de clases
estaría más frito que un pollo en lugar
de se llama so de ser les propongo que
os enseñen a respetar respetar a
nuestros padres a nuestros maestros ya
nuestras autoridades a diferencia de la
obediencia ciega el respeto es la
audiencia pensante
es decir que si ustedes nos enseñan a
pensar nosotros aprenderemos a respetar
los niños no somos marionetas más sin
embargo si los padres y los maestros nos
tratan como tales nos acostumbraremos a
ello a depender de sus hilos ficticios
que no se utilizarán durante toda la
infancia
esto muchas veces hace que cuando seamos
mayores nunca podamos tener obtener un
conocimiento fácil ya que nunca podremos
aprender a tomar nuestras sesiones a
poder ser responsables entre muchas
otras cosas
si bien nuestros padres nunca dejarán de
ser nuestros padres y nosotros aunque
estemos en la otra punta del mundo nunca
dejaremos de ser sus hijos
alguna vez deberemos dejar el nido de
debemos de dejar ese hogar de la niñez
para convertirnos en adultos
responsables en adultos que
probablemente tengan hijos y enseñen
algo a ellos
para concluir les quiero dejar tres
cosas la primera es
que a mi manera de ver la educación que
siempre hemos tenido necesita un cambio
un cambio que nos dé mejores
herramientas para que cuando seamos
adultos podamos tomar nuestras propias
decisiones aprender más fácil y no
depender de otras personas segunda cosa
siempre recuerden ustedes no están
educando a hijos ustedes están educando
a futuros padres a futuros maestros y a
futuros tutores que serán como un espejo
de lo que ustedes les enseñen que le
transmitieran a sus hijos así hasta el
fin de los tiempos y tercera cosa que
les quiero decir
si ustedes los toman nosotros seremos
adultos pasivos adultos temerosos que
nunca irán más allá de ese pequeño
margen de que alguien nos diga que hacer
es decir nunca me te va a pedir que seas
un genio en cambio si ustedes nos
enseñan a pensar nosotros tendremos las
herramientas para cambiarnos a nosotros
mismos y de alguna u otra manera de
poder cambiar el mundo muchas gracias
[Aplausos]
[Música]